(alternative rock music)
♫ Put to bed your old
ideas about my friend Ben
♫ True we holler every day,
but it isn't really like that
♫ He's the one I shoot the
shit with when I'm hurtin' bad
♫ Slasher movie part three
♫ Geeking on the twist end
♫ If you got a girl who's got a friend
♫ Then you should just believe
♫ You've got a girl who's got a friend
♫ And you should trust in me
♫ If you've got a girl who
says she's just got a friend
♫ Then you should just believe
♫ You treat me like some grand deceiver
♫ 'Cause you never just believe
♫ Put to bed your old
ideas about my friend Ben
♫ True, I love him big time
♫ But I didn't mean it like that
♫ He's the one who's got my back
♫ I'm always his fan
♫ Got the broken glass bottles trash
♫ role models nihilism down pat
♫ If you got a girl who's got a friend
♫ Then you should just believe
♫ You've got a girl who's got a friend
♫ And you should trust in me
♫ If you've got a girl who
says she's just got a friend
♫ Then you should just believe
♫ You treat me like some grand deceiver
♫ 'Cause you never just believe
(groovy, rock synth and guitar)
(heavier guitar)
♫ They've got the look,
they've got the hots
♫ Objectify these boys
♫ They've got the look,
they've got the hots
♫ Objectify these boys
♫ They've got the look,
you've got no trust
♫ Objectify these boys
♫ Treat me like a grand deceiver
(groovy rock music)
♫ Put to bed your wrong
ideas about my old friends
♫ Before I’m drowning in abasement
♫ Drowning in abasement
♫ Objectify these boys
♫ Wish I was a grand deceiver
♫ You never just believe
(modern music)